[Música]
estas buenas tardes a todos
y cuando la gente escucha el nombre de
esta conferencia que se llama tu honor
es tu cerebro normalmente siempre me
preguntan bueno si no eres tu cerebro
entonces qué chingados eres y lo que yo
le digo a la gente es que
muchísimos filósofos han estudiado esa
pregunta que somos a través de siglos y
siglos y siglos y nos ha podido llegar a
una conclusión después de diez años de
estudiar el cerebro humano se me hace
tan increíble como la respuesta siempre
estuvo frente a mí y nunca la pude ver y
cuando encontré esa respuesta dije
quiero que esto todo el mundo lo sepa y
además de lo que me dedico a parte de
conferencias explicando realmente que
somos
pero para antes de decírselo necesito
explicarles un poco cómo funciona el
cerebro
voy a empezar a decir ciertas cosas que
nos van a deprimir tranquilos al final
les voy a dar esperanza
el cerebro es un órgano que su única
única única función es la supervivencia
no le importa nada más esa es una parte
difícil de entender la única función del
cerebro es que estés vivo y si lo has
logrado el hecho de estar aquí pues que
lo están logrando nada más puede fallar
una vez si falla pues dejan de avalista
entonces el cerebro no le interesa tu
bienestar esa es una parte complicada de
entender puedes tener una relación por
ejemplo no sé que tu novio te maltrata
psicológicamente tu trabajo está
espantoso te maltratan tienes un carro
que parece que va a explotar cuando lo
enciende es un departamento que huele
aún húmedos a toda tu vida es un
desastre todo es un infierno el cerebro
no le importa lo que quieras que estés
vivo es lo único que le interesa
y ahí viene lo interesante el cerebro
libera dos químicos que vengo a
hablarles el día de hoy uno es la
dopamina otro es el cortisol entre
muchos que libera quiero hablar de esos
dos nada más para este tema la dopamina
es un químico que cuando lo libera tú
sientes placer te sientes bien sientes
bienestar esas veces por ejemplo cuando
estás trabajando y te acuerdas que en la
noche vas a tener una fiesta que te
gusta y te hace un rato de felicidad
acabas de liberar dopamina y esas veces
cuando te sale el de adentro y
que empiezas a insultar a la gente y
perforen guiffrey y estás bajo los
efectos del cortisol son contrarias una
de la otra
la gente que todo el tiempo está de buen
humor pase lo que pase y hasta te cae
mal esa gente es tan constantemente
liberando dopamina y la gente que todo
el que es irritable que les quieres
acercar ni preguntar nada es la gente
que todo el día está liberando cortisol
lo que me encantaría que te estés
preguntando en este momento es porque ya
te estoy entendiendo gerardo ya
entendido para mina bienestar cortisol
se siente mal cuando chingados liberamos
una o la otra es muy interesante y vamos
a regresar al primer punto el cerebro es
única función es la supervivencia
entonces a la información que tiene de
todo lo que has aprendido y vivido y lo
que tú tienes ya por nacimiento por
genética todo el tiempo está haciendo
una evaluación y cuando el cerebro
considera
que aumentaron tus posibilidades de
vivir te premia con dopamina y te
sientes bien cuando comes por ejemplo
cuando el cerebro en su información
calcula que aumentaron tus posibilidades
de morir te castiga con cortisol y te
sientes estresado este fenómeno o este
sistema se llama conductismo y todo el
tiempo está funcionando todo el día no
es exclusivo de los humanos desde los
mamíferos esto y voy a utilizar un perro
para explicar el conductismo tú quieres
entrenar un perro para que cuando
llegues te salude levantando la patita
entonces cómo lo haces
cada que levanta la pata del perro tú le
aumentó las posibilidades de vivir por
ejemplo dándole alimentos entonces el
cerebro del perro libera dopamina se
siente bien premio
si no levanta la patita el perro aumentó
las posibilidades de morir como puedas
un golpe libera cortisol se siente mal y
qué sucede si repite si repite si
repites este patrón va a llegar un
momento en el que el cerebro del perro
se va a confundir y va a creer que
levantar la pata es necesaria para estar
vivo es cuando tú llegas el perro te
levanta la pata y dice hay qué lindo me
está saludando no es el conductismo ya
funcionando el humano funciona
exactamente igual existe ya este sistema
de dopamina y cortisol por cuestiones
naturales de nacimiento les pongo un
ejemplo el estornudo es un mecanismo de
defensa cuando el cerebro detecta que
hay un intruso en los ductos
respiratorios manda la señal de que
tienes que estornudar y te empieza a
mandar cortisol es decir incomodidad
estrés porque porque hay algo que están
aumentando las posibilidades de morir y
una vez que tú estornuda
si se fijan es placentero porque te
premia con dopamina aumentaron tus
posibilidades
esto es de nacimiento naces con ese
sistema sin embargo
desde niño te fueron diciendo si alguien
estornuda dile salud
dile salud no es el grosero de salud y
empiezan a crear una condición de que es
algo necesario de hacer ese utiliza el
mismo sistema nada más que ya es
aprendido recibir y está ahorita
estornudo todos me dirían en coro salud
les vale madre mi salud lo dicen porque
les da placer liberar esa dopamina ahora
imagina la cantidad de información que
tenemos ahora que ya eres adulto que ya
está en este sistema de cortisol
dopamina todo el tiempo todo el tiempo
todo el tiempo
volviendo a la parte donde les decía que
el cerebro no le interesa tu bienestar
le interesa tu supervivencia analiza que
normalmente repite siempre el mismo
patrón analizar el camino que agarras de
tu casa al trabajo siempre es el mismo
siempre es el mismo y aquí te seguro que
vas al mismo cajero automático a la
misma gasolinera vas y desde el mismo
platillo en el mismo restaurante una y
otra vez porque el cerebro ya conoce que
eso funciona no le importa si te gustó o
no y si un día tú dices a partir de
ahora voy a empezar a agarrar un nuevo
camino primo el trabajo va a empezar a
mandar cortisol cortisol cortisol una
vez que ya no me gusta mi trabajo me voy
a cambiar de trabajo cortisol cortisol
cortisol ya no me gusta mi pareja ya
estoy hasta la madre de este vato que
nada más me está friegue y friegue dije
me lo mandó cortisol cortisol porque no
va a querer salir de lo que conoce ya
estás en ese sistema de conducta
pero cuál es la diferencia que tenemos a
diferencia de los perros el perro no
sabe que te está saludando el perro no
sabe que tiene este sistema el perro no
tiene la capacidad de entender lo que
pasa es que te libera dopamina si no
tiene esa capacidad nosotros sí porque
si la tenemos ellos no porque tenemos
conciencia
y la consciencia es algo que no se sabe
mucho al día de hoy que es la
consciencia está en la parte frontal del
cerebro es un área que se llama
neocórtex y es exclusiva del ser humano
la conciencia hasta el día de hoy
estudios hemos visto en estudios y es
impresionante ver lo que ese pequeño
pedacito que le llamamos conciencia
emite ondas electromagnéticas y recibe
ondas electromagnéticas todavía no
sabemos porque un profesor de
antropología me decía gerardo te has
puesto a pensar que muy probablemente la
conciencia no está dentro de nosotros
sino viene de afuera esto ya se está
votando y me decía si yo te pongo una
televisión
y tú no entiendes cómo funcionan las
ondas de radio
juraría es por tu madre que las imágenes
que están en esa televisión están
saliendo adentro de la caja y si yo te
dijera la transmisión viene de
inglaterra de eeuu de ciudad de méxico
me dirías estás loco no puede ser que
así sea la conciencia no sabemos esto es
un algo filosófico que me compartió el
que me deja pensando pero no tenemos
idea que son esas ondas no sabemos por
qué tenemos la conciencia y más
preguntas que respuestas pero te voy a
decir lo que sí sabemos sabemos que lo
tenemos y tenemos la capacidad de saber
que esto funciona y tenemos las
capacidades ser conscientes
cosas que queremos que incluso vayan en
contra la supervivencia natural del
cerebro por eso ser humano hace tantas
pendejadas como conducir borracho no
tendría sentido porque va en contra la
supervivencia en realidad es que la
conciencia va por encima del sistema de
supervivencia y esto es lo que vuelve
muy interesante que en realidad no somos
el cerebro
un gato un perro un elefante solamente
repite los mismos patrones y si no tiene
que atender una necesidad biológica está
echado
y por eso empezamos con esa dualidad de
extraña nosotros por ejemplo la típica
si yo digo a partir del lunes william
gimnasio y me va a poner bien bueno ya
que a mis cuadritos y todo pero es el
lunes en la noche me estoy comiendo una
pizza y tomando un 12 de cerveza cuál es
la lógica con eso porque no tiene un
sentido lo que yo quiero con mis
acciones
por eso digo la respuesta siempre estuvo
en frente de nuestros ojos porque
nosotros no somos el cerebro
nosotros somos nosotros o sea la
conciencia que en el humano está por
encima de este sistema de supervivencia
que ya tiene entonces el sentido natural
del cerebro es comer esa pizza y esas
cervezas no quieren gastar la energía el
sentido natural del ser del cerebro es
que no te salgas del trabajo que no
emprenda es el proyecto que quieres que
no salgas de la relación que no quieres
o te atrevas a hacer cosas
cuando desde ayer que he estado pensando
mucho por ejemplo en que iba a estar
parado aquí frente ustedes yo me empiezo
a inundar de miedo es el pánico escénico
yo tengo ese miedo desde hace dos días
él es el cerebro todo el tiempo diciendo
no lo hagas no lo hagas no lo hagas no
lo hagas es una estupidez vas a estar
frente a un público a ver cámara si
cometes un error aumentan tus
posibilidades de morir porque sois un
ser social
pero ese miedo no es mío
ese miedo de mi cerebro y por eso como
quiera yo estoy aquí por eso de todo
esto que les enseño hoy
me gustaría que se lleven dos cosas la
primera
aceptar que tenemos un cerebro y que lo
único que le importa es tu supervivencia
eso no va a cambiar naciste con eso me
asiste con un sistema que cuando quieras
cometer un cambio que tú consideras que
te beneficia el cerebro no va a querer
que lo hagas te va a mandar cortisol es
decir te va a mandar estrés te va a
mandar miedo te va a mandar cosas para
que no lo hagas es natural eso es lo
primero que sepas es inevitable lo vas a
sentir piensa en eso que siempre has
querido hacer pero por una u otra razón
no te atreves eso que no te atreves es
el miedo que está mandando el cerebro
porque el miedo es un mecanismo diseñado
para huir
lo segundo que quiero que te lleves es
que entiendas que tú eres conciencia es
decir que eres tú yo soy gerardo yo no
soy mi cerebro yo estoy por encima de
este miedo pues aunque yo lo sienta si
lo sé no lo voy a evitar lo voy a sentir
tú y yo como quiera lo voy a hacer
no me voy a morir es interesante verlo
si yo mañana salgo a hacer ejercicio en
la mañana porque hicieron mis cuadritos
no me voy a morir aunque el cerebro lo
considera me va a castigar por este
conducto ismo que del que les hablo pero
no me voy a morir piensa en ese proyecto
que quieres hacer y tú como ya lo vas a
hacer con si no a pesar de las
circunstancias el cerebro te va a mandar
el miedo para que no lo hagas pero tú
estás por encima de eso porque tú no
eres tu cerebro gracias
[Música]